Android developer office hours with me
today little fluffy Android is always
for the first time Stefan Lintner is
joining us he's joined our team from
Stuttgart Jimmy yeah actually
Frank Frankfurt Alberto originally
coming from Stuttgart
okay yeah he's clever he's joined our
team will be based out of the London
office as well and I so welcome Stefan
bring some new testing skills to our
team that we with all those questions on
testing that you asked so in the future
moderators for these feel free to add
some more questions on testing a few
Stefan will be able to fill in the
blanks we're also of course is Matthew
got a new and hi Nick butcher and we've
got two people joined us in the Hangout
already we've got Bill and clones hi
guys thank you for joining us and Chris
Bane's is out sick yeah okay well
sickness is
as usual we'll be discussing Android
development topics but we won't be
discussing roadmap features these will
be released that sort of thing someone
else is just joined us in the Hangout
hey um good to see you again thank you
for joining us today
hey John your hands either on mute or
trying to catch okay before we have us
delve into the moderator does anyone
have any questions from the Hangout for
us as giuseppe as well hey Giuseppe good
to see many questions for inside the one
of the Hangout today a question for you
the async task point can be in single
threaded to then beam parallel processed
and then back to single threaded why did
you do that because it broke stuff but
yeah essentially people are relying on
the fact that async tasks wouldn't come
back in the order that they were
requested it and as soon as we said it's
a multi-threaded this
coming back in other orders and
applications across the Playstore
started to fail so we did revert it back
again which makes life particularly
awkward for you but you can specify so
you can put the thread pool executors
specified in your waiting tasks if you
like it the multi thread it or not if
you like it in its yeah we always
recommend specifying which 24 focus
behavior may vary we were having a
debate about that yesterday and I did a
bunch of reading so I thought well I'll
join the hangout and ask so yeah yeah
it's a good question
we've we've had that many conferences
before as well and it's just one of
those things we do test a lot of
applications with each release of
Android and we didn't spot this
particular issue arising it was even
early honeycomb right but it got
switched over sometimes sometimes it's
also about performance if you have one
thread it might be faster than spawning
multiple threads because I've seen
applications were ever spawned like 20
to 40 threats especially ones crawling
on this view just as an addition that's
the reason it happened at that time as
well it was all single core devices up
until when and then we got the dual core
devices all right let's make use of it
let's make all these applications
multi-core we're just join us there
we've got Yossi hey yo C it's good to
see you in the Hangout again hi guys
hang out news weather I think we had a
discussion on the new format which you
tried out for the first time last week
compressing it down to half an hour and
trying to keep his real focus on the
content and we there were some people
saying if folks were still brushed and
I'm sorry but also a lot of people seems
to very much enjoy it and especially
looking at the YouTube stats and people
seem to have got a lot more than that so
we're going to stick with the half-hour
format yeah it's unfortunate the people
who interact with us in the Hangout
really seem to appreciate the the time
to chat thank you to the guys who do
join us here you do make half the
for us but the stats are just incredible
but the five or 6,000 relaunches are new
to you yeah we've done shows now one
hour 45 minutes and 30 minutes and the
short of the show the more of the show
people watch not just percentage-wise
but actually in real time in real
minutes so by the time we get to an hour
show five minutes we just told like Rito
does on this weekend okay anything else
for inside the Hangout can ask questions
can I do yes we are implementing a new
application that is a based on the
module concept for modern concept I mean
that the base application must be able
to lowered external library enjoy I
would like it to ask if there is any
suggestion from you guys how to
implement a good management of external
modem so the user will be able for
example paying a worm through the in-app
system some special model and he paid
then we will supply the download link of
the child library and then the app would
be able to load at runtime this model
class loaders learning classes
rheumatism
so you asking whether is technically
possible or the best way to do it though
what's the best way to dilute it
so the the only written guidance we have
on that though I'm aware of at the
moment is on Android developers blog
I'll find it for you now there was a
post written by Fred Chung apparently
which does go into the details of the
best way to dynamically load class files
other than that Android developers Bugs
Bunny and the connected question what do
you think about the permission security
definition security will be connected
inside the will be attached to the
single library that we load at runtime
or old permission must be in the main
application which has an API where you
can write your own modules and runtime
they will pull them in so there's an
example code you could probably take if
it'll look at so that's at
code.google.com slash p project / - book
anyone we could put this link in the
truck I've posted our link into the G+
thread for this hangout for the class
loading and nickel do go home free and
everyone looking for it and right
you question but the time that you find
I will add something Richard well I was
just trying to find this solution
because I was thinking that the
permission can be could to be included
in the single jar and not in the simple
single library and not in the main one
but at the end of the day if I have to
include the permissions in the manifest
then in the main application I mean then
this would not solve a whole lot a real
problem because the real problem today
is that I would like to have specific
feeders that users can buy separately
and then when he buy separately
he know that this special feeder needs
some special permission that is the real
problem
yeah so there's two solutions that the
filters list on the Android on the Play
Store themselves just list the filters
as separate purchases on the Play Store
and they can have their own permissions
and link to them from inside your
application the other thing would be
downloading apk shove the device and
then calling the installer to install
those apks and then show the permission
screen but that wouldn't be allowed if
you were shipping it after the Play
Store so the only way would be to called
you please explain who you beetle please
explain better the second the
solution well the second solution
doesn't really apply because it would be
effectively writing your own marketplace
where he would download apk files and
then call the device's installer to
install them and then the user would get
to accept the permissions but you're not
allowed to ship other marketplaces
inside the Play Store so it wouldn't
apply the only way of permissions is to
have it possible do you think possible
that in theaters we have the optional
permissions
as per the disclaimer at the start of
the show we wouldn't gamble is to answer
that question I don't know no idea
Giuseppe no idea but is a suggestion
must be brought to the to the main blade
redesign absolutely because optional
permissions and optional permissions
will help us to don't lose it
we know that CyanogenMod has implemented
it and it has been discussed but there's
nothing to talk about
unfortunately either way okay
first but where do you get the Android
heart t-shirts more than this yeah they
went to everyone who worked on the jelly
bean project
oh no Drake erased Android but is there
a way to change the private channel
graphic that appears in the Google Play
Store
I don't we I go that's the same question
maybe was you um I was just surely
emailed to the guys um and we don't know
yet
it's not in the documents I looked it up
from Sweden asks how do you open a
custom file type from a team at that if
I make an intent filter for application
slash whole history and a fall pattern
we've maybe in still tries to open all
other file types as well as y hat like
files or ePub etcetera we've had this
question in so basically taking even if
you just say that your app can handle
all of its dreams then it will
yeah it's too white other types not just
the type that you want yeah yeah there's
a widow that and recently just bear with
us the second is we all stare at screens
momentarily okay so what I'll do is I'll
go on to one of the questions that came
in on the Google+ stream from Jen's hole
any suggestions on creating a floating
window on top of fragments so it depends
kind of what you're trying to do with
that one but my gut instinct would be it
kind of sounds like you want to just
have something in a relative layout at
the activity layer and then essentially
add the fragments within that and just
make sure that the window element is
kind of the last thing and the relative
layout was kind of floating on top if
you can kind of give us some more
context if that's not suitable may be a
good idea but ultimately it kind of
sounds like what you want to do and say
floating window I'm assuming you're not
yeah
that's what I do relative layout at the
activity then trial pretty yeah you
could do a download and customize it
there'll be another way of doing it that
might actually be killing a dollar
pregnant yeah you could but if by
floating he means he wants to move it
around as well or what they just was you
could do an activity with just a
transparent background and then have a
little chunk oh yeah you could track
touch input
yeah and animate them around
different options yeah what you have to
do I guess would be yeah Jen's if you
have any more details on exactly what
you're trying to do just put them on the
thread will see them and we'll see if we
can get you a more precise answer mixed
opinions Nexus 10 out there is an answer
on stick or flow and exactly what he
asked so I think yeah unfortunately
didn't get a chance to read through the
moderator questions before the show
today due to Chris Bane's unexpected
illness so a slightly less prepared
because you yesterday P have put the
link for that dynamic library loading in
the Google+ thread for this post so if
you go to Google+ where it says you'll
see my name in the link and through that
no problem Vibha
who's usually on inside the hangout with
us but not today says good to see Stefan
congratulations
thank you wasn't and he says he could
post some code anything else do we have
any other questions for inside the
Hangout be kind of short on material or
anything you just want to talk about you
guys have become and you might want to
talk about it about the Android puzzlers
project sure sure
well first forward first of all for us
welcome Stefan good to see you there in
London we've registered as an official
foundation now so it's good so we can
now when we're an easily get some fun
from from companies and and we have some
great meetups lined up so one is the
code puzzlers and tips and tricks we're
going to do a couple of workshops as
well we're going to do something on
design so a couple of good meetups yeah
and a little party because we're well an
official foundation so parties are
always good what is an official
Foundation oh just register with the
Chamber of Commerce and tax office so
we've been doing mainly and he said
small meetups but as some simply a
prizes involved and and large catering
stuff and it's easier to to do it
officially so we can do better meetups
there yeah yeah so I found a good place
well there's basically saying that you
need to register for both your
application type and the orchids tree so
it sounds like you're doing the right
thing by listening for the application
mashup of the stream but are you also
providing the hosts the park posts and
path pattern as well specify like like
just not like I think you actually need
to specify I think it probably might be
they're not specifying the path pattern
correctly I think you do and dot star
and then escape the dots and then mad so
rather than just mob as your path
passively speed don't start back slash
dot map I think is the problem that we
don't specify which is why it's apparent
agree completely to regex name I will
post a link to tox
J Smith or tux tree estimate probably
tux jake Smith I got for from the UK has
asked a question of Kant's answer
birthday some users Galaxy s2 and since
he is Lee knows better unable to
register with the Google Cloud messaging
service when you
his chat app missing Google accounts
firewalls blocking some ports have been
ruled out can you think of other reasons
that's a tricky one why wouldn't GCM on
these devices obviously not having an
internet connection firewalls missing
Google accounts have been the the first
moment of thought
problem with the Play Store caching
maybe on their device Google Cloud
messaging yeah my services yes no no
usually I mean if people are installing
the applications through the Play Store
the Play Store is up to date and Play
services what we have today
maybe the updater GCM doesn't work for
those devices thanks yes to that was
hugely widespread big issues on it yeah
I can say we don't have issues here with
God exists or ZT with GCM and it's just
some of them I think again unfortunate
us case you're gonna have to get some
more info P that puts more locking
inside your application or find a
reproducible test case find get in
contact with one of the people who have
told you that their application the
application spending on their device and
I have apps on the Play Store and I
reached out to my users my where I need
help debugging things like this it's
probably best just to do that see if
they can send you any screenshots of the
situation maybe you'll notice there's
something wrong with the network
connectivity you who knows it's a
strange one though it'd be nice to find
out where it works we get a murrain of
hell is back again hey marina pal what's
the best way to flag a version with
increased functionality to separate it
from the commercial version with
unlimited use of functionality a version
with increased functionality is opposed
to a commercial version with unlimited
use of functionality is there a best
practice I don't really want to create
branches did you get that aversion so
you have a standard version a version
with increased functionality and a
commercial version with unlimited use so
maybe it's a case if you you could buy
one it's a free trial and then you can
buy it or subscribe to the whole thing
the commercial one yeah so I guess
rather than having three separate apps
to do each of those you just want to say
they've got this and who is this the
flagger two users in the Play Store to
flag it inside your code so you can keep
one source tree but be able to build
three different versions of it if it's
one source tree with three different
versions of it okay sorry yeah okay
hopefully that did answer your question
how is the best way to become an Android
developer how is the best way hey in the
chat how is the best way to become an
Android developer go to developers to
android.com
it's definitely the best way to start
download the bundle SDK it will install
the Android SDK and Eclipse for you and
then we have a whole bunch of tutorials
right from the beginner stuff through to
advanced topics so start having like
through the tutorials if you already a
Java developer you'll find it I feel
pretty easy you just have to get the UI
layer sorted out and yeah and maybe see
if there's a local and Android
developers meter or Google technology
user group or something like this in
your area so
gets me some like-minded people they
will help there's also tons of YouTube
videos on becoming an Android developer
one guy did a series of a hundred
YouTube videos and takes you right
through from the Eclipse to being
supposed to be an expert developer and
there's lots of other resources online
check out the activity lifecycle and
then everything else that makes up an
Android app intense services and your
are a trend bosses receivers yeah you
could do it wrinkles and look at her
samples the samples are very good as is
always the way just get stuck in make
your first Android app info him there
get excited about it running around with
on your phone it's the best thing about
program for mobile devices right you
have it on you all the time you can show
it off people suggest things you go ha
and you try them out and then you just
hooked onto it and can't stop I have
this isn't a cool awful what did it say
I think it's one of the nicest features
you can have on the device
now you full screen shows us hey can you
see it you see me no okay say you're on
the screen and you want to go to the all
the applications instead of pressing the
home button and trying to get to the
drawer and stuff you just swipe to the
left and you have all the apps all the
starred apps
no it's it's nice because you can have
recently used apps also available here
and also starred app so it's also active
like when I'm on chrome Chrome and I do
the
against the previous time now no you can
you can I'll open some tabs here some
tabs are open and I don't know if you
can see them just second many
applications that interfere with the
behavior of other applications can get I
think it's a cool app no I didn't do it
it's a friend of mine on XDA else and
the link here to the chatter - the G
thread G+ thread to people to see I
think it's nice to see you
and the answer is no only supported nice
Berlin is for each other or with the MDK
there are applications up there such as
the scripting layer for Android and so
off which will run as an interpretive
language on the device and eg some
scripting in other languages but they on
any routes you can make apart native
there are other options out there I
think things like mono or stuff of
actual trying to do cross compilation
actually no I think it will just take
Misha as you say can you please please
answer my question I've got a class a
few minutes no need to go but I wanted
to do something with embedded text to
speech but he wanted to do the offline
stuff so you know before you is how to
connect a server and now there's the
ability to do it on the Android device
itself without having to go it's not
recognition yeah okay speech that would
be the voice recognition because you
I bet six pitches recognizing oh yeah
gun the other way
yeah so that's the reason why that I've
confused it you confused so that might
be it well I'm going to use offline
text-to-speech in my app yeah embedded
tester speech yeah and he tried to end
it what we should what we have a bit
more detail why did you see the question
it's so I'll read it out what they do
no no it wasn't that nope disappeared
that is weird sorry me sure I can't see
the question anywhere it was in there
for I see nothing
yeah so yeah thank you for joining us
again and joining us the same time next
week and put your questions into the
moderator yeah but on this screen is
showing the ultimate stopwatch okay
weary surprises good to design you
ultimate stop worst and went live
yesterday
Boston box against the algorithm says
join us next week thank you very much
for your time and Google's live
programming as well so check out the a
pinnacle on Friday and what is on action
next week please any questions in the
moderator by very much bye guys thanks
for everything